billions of views the moral support of
nations weeks of gushing coverage for
media outlets around the world
olympic glory is a heady dream come true
for almost
every athlete who makes it but it's no
easy way to get rich
between trainers facility time and state
of the art equipment
getting to the games can cost athletes a
lot of money
so much so that some athletes use
gofundme to pay their way
while some champions are backed by
lucrative endorsement deals
the surest way to leave tokyo with a
windfall this summer
is to arrive with one many of the
highest paid athletes at this year's
olympics are famous
olympians or professional athletes
leading the list is nba star kevin
durant who earned 75 million dollars
over the past year
with two olympic gold medals under his
belt the brooklyn netstar has seen his
investments off the court
rival his prolific play on the court
durant has become the league's
latest media mogul with the start of his
media network boardroom
a stake in mls's philadelphia union and
his own venture capital firm
35 ventures basketball players aren't
the only athletes heading into the
olympics with hefty fortunes
tennis star naomi osaka who's repping
her home country of japan
is the second highest earning athlete on
our list with 60 million dollars
for the second straight year osaka has
shattered the earnings records for
female athletes
surpassing veteran top earner serena
williams osaka earned 55 million dollars
in endorsements and 5 million dollars in
prize money with more than 20
endorsement partners
including google louis vuitton and
levi's osaka ranks number 12 on forbes's
highest paid athletes list
golf star rory mcilroy earned 32 million
dollars and is number five on our list
repping northern ireland mcelroy has
become one of the most
marketable players off the course the 32
year old golfer has made nearly 90
of his 32 million dollars in earnings
off the course from
sponsorships with brands such as nike
omega and united health group
among others mcelroy's largest on the
course payday was 15 million dollars for
winning the 2019
fedex cup
[Music]
you